[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC FROEMLING: My
name is Eric Froemling,
and I'm an indie
developer making a game
all by myself called BombSquad.
I started writing BombSquad
purely as a hobby back
when I was finishing
up art school.
I just wrote it as something
to play with my friends
at our little dorky
get togethers.
I really enjoy creating
models, so everything
in the game-- whether it's
a character or a set--
is created in real
life and then brought
into the game, which gives
a really unique style.
And for many years it
just existed as a hobby.
And then a few
years ago I decided
to put it out and see
what I could do with it.
And now it's my livelihood.
Before Player Analytics,
I was pretty much blind.
I was just guessing what
my players were doing,
and what was causing
them to spend,
and where they were
spending their time,
but I didn't really know.
When I started using the tools,
it was a very eye opening
experience.
I could suddenly see
the low hanging fruit,
where I could improve retention
or improve monetization
in the game.
BombSquad is a multiplayer game
at heart, but 90% of my players
were going down the
single player path.
So that helped me
focus my efforts
and add more content
and more things for them
to do when they were on
that side of the game.
Player Analytics
showed me that players
were earning more than they
were spending in the game,
so I was able to
rebalance my economy
and make a significant
positive impact on my revenue.
I immediately saw 140% lift in
the average revenue per user,
as well as a 67% lift in
average revenue per paying user.
By looking at the Player
Progression Chart,
I also learned that players
were having a hard time
getting past level two
or three in my game.
It was too hard.
So I went back
and rebalanced it.
I added an easy mode.
And after that, I saw a
3.6x increase in the number
of levels that players
were completing,
which helped increase
my retention.
The Events Viewer is
useful a number of ways.
One way I use it is
as a sanity check.
After I release the game, I
can check the Events Viewer
to make sure people's frames
per second are still good,
and everything's running
well with the game.
Another thing I learned
from the Events Viewers
is that my tutorial is too long.
And I see most people skip
it after about 10 seconds.
Player Analytics really
helped me to open my eyes
and see what I was doing
right, what I was doing wrong,
and correct the
ship to the point
where now it's
working financially.
My biggest piece of
advice to developers
is put something out there.
See what you did wrong,
look at the numbers,
use tools like Player Analytics.
Correct things and try again.
And just be persistent, and
eventually you'll get it right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]